all right welcome to chest of the 21st
century when the other GM's take over
they're gonna show you games for the
21st century I will also show you that
except I have a caveat my person has to
be born in the 21st century so you two
have a chance yeah you both my 21st
century so today's topic of discussion
will be someone who's here next month
Roofing Li he's the brother of of Rex's
nemesis Rachel Lee and roofing Lee his
feet a rating is over 2,500 and his USCF
ratings over 2,600 and he'll be here
next month for the norm tournament where
he's gonna play me in the first round
then his ratings will dip slightly but
these things will happen they might go
up in the later rounds now Roofing Li
every year has a much higher rating
because he's only 15 he was born in 2001
in fact he may not even be 15 yet who
knows I asked him when he was like I
don't know okay yeah he was war a long
time ago can he remember and this is a
game he played in the US Open in 2014
his feet a rating was 2284 unless those
were USCF ratings at 50/50 and he was
black in this position and each side has
a two rooks and five pawns now actually
either move that white plays here is
okay it's sort of ante disestablished no
that's not the word it's not that move
you want to play rook takes rook on
doubling your opponent's Center pawns
but it's okay and the movie played was
all right it was rookie tier and this
game roofing Lee had the black pieces
his opponent was a 2000 player now
normally in the endgame you're trying to
do one thing Queen a passed pawn and
black has to pass pawns are possibly one
passed fun I never know what the answers
let's vote who says both pawns are
passed to raise your hand who says only
the front one is who abstains the
extensions have the highest rated
players have seen that was interesting
okay yeah I don't know either so I think
it's to pass pawns
anyway all right so usually in an end
game you want to Queen you're passed
pawns although I think White's doing a
pretty reasonable job making sure you
don't do that however there's something
you always want to do in chess checkmate
and White's King doesn't have a plethora
of squares right Selina
also what's plethora and what's your
name okay so yeah but I forgot it was
like four seconds ago
okay so black decided if he checked me
at his opponent that would be reasonable
right then Simon been Simon's having a
tough time over there you people at home
don't realize how hard he's working you
unknown girl why not Rick Ji Won that
rook ff1 it was funny I was playing a
guy and he had rooks doubled on the file
some file and he wrote like rook you
know F and I was like both of you
rickshaw run F he was like yeah what do
you want me to do and I said eight or
one he goes oh he never thought of that
I was like why did you write F if
they're both had a half like he knew
they were both on a few still rode out
okay so you played rook one of the rooks
and the other one it must be very very
very very very slightly more accurate to
play rugby one so your opponent has last
choice or it's where I could play rook F
once they have a chance to blunder mm
yeah so Rick f one must be better let's
the guy play rook e1 let's see what he
did oh good player rook F one is that
what you suggested okay
so white played rook e1 then resigned no
let's see I can't make that Joker she'll
get mad at me okay
so King B to rook g1 threatening would
be one check me
okay now what should white do you see
pawn to c4 very explosive your answer c4
and the other moves that dairy inside
which nobody can hear with me c3 and I
think that's it right let's follow it
voting's fun okay who says c412 who says
c3 well the 500 players better than all
the experts of minsters c4 losses and c3
white slightly worse yeah and white was
i rated player so he played the losing
move yeah c3 is better because c3 unlike
c4 has a threat
c3 I want to place eat eggs before got
me yum-yum
and my rips on h4 oh and then you'll
never made me because you got no be pawn
after c4 you're still getting mated you
guys were alike I'm gonna Queen my sea
pond and I was like why do you have
funny voices then he was like I'm from
Germany I don't like I all right ever
mind okay so in this position we want to
play rook b1 me whoever rip me one is
not me because of king c2 you agree okay
so we need one of our works on c1 and
one of our rooks on b1 right did you
agree yeah cool okay so how do we do
that
should we ask roof ingly he's the star
of the class how do we get the rooks on
C 1 and B 1 that's what you and a white
mist but that roofing ly 21st century
anyone Grand Master yes rook to a-1
okay now I'll give you a hint black is
good to go here next to move and then
rook a2 b1 me
okay and if you play rook see to
stopping rook c1 that's very funny
because then either rook should be one
is made probably the rook on anyone cuz
that's less energy yeah okay acceptor ok
whyme black's winning oh well she played
c3 and I could play C takes b4 then
White's better yeah okay so white played
rookie four that's a good move
correct that's why it was it was a good
move I was kidding
yeah then after you're here you resign
good defense heads-up deed game and you
know what that means that he didn't play
see here's what happened I know what
happened but you don't roofing Levi
doesn't even know what happened what I
do okay this is why you're all the worst
okay except for you you're great cuz
they're all the worst okay the reason
you all the worst is you do a white did
you're like why did black play Rock a
one oh I know he'll play rook here check
King c2 rep takes a to check winning
upon and probably winning maybe maybe
not so he stopped it he played rookie
for now if you play rook takes a to
check out like King takes rook and my
rips are defending each other right so
now if he does this then this doesn't
work anymore because this rook defended
this rook he thought he was being very
clever and then after rook c1 he
probably wasn't very happy because now
me and there's no defense now iris
prefers the move that doesn't allow made
king c2 that's what he should have done
and after rook takes me to his games
terrible but you keep going right yeah
who while you're up upon you're gonna
win the b3 pawn things terrible for
white I would say Creek a3 is good
I would think rook takes rook and rook
v1 is good I would think Rick takes Rick
and Rick c1 is good
I don't like trainings I probably go
here
anyway white would continue playing and
eventually lose as opposed to losing in
one move but the reason he played rookie
four is because he did the Seabrooke
Siwon Rigby one me he wasn't worried a
bit getting made it because it was an
end game but then he got made it so
reminds me became I play to get treated
Pulgar but I have no evidence because
there was 15 minute came and there was
no nobody kept score so so I maybe I
imagined it okay next game no I didn't
imagine it okay roofing Lee's white and
this is the year after his rating is
another hundred points just like you
guys every year under points after 20
years you're pretty good well you'll be
almost as high rated as me in 20 years
that's a really funny joke but nobody
got it okay the joke was if he gets a
hundred points every 20 years I'm still
higher rated than them right yeah that's
funny because for like Irish she'd be
like 4,000 alright so here black has the
advantage but White's fighting back okay
and roofing Lee's white and he's playing
axel Bachman who actually I believe
that's I'm wrong his good friends with
Alejandro who was just here but he's not
here so but he was here that's all that
matters and this was planted a norm
tournament roofing Lee trying to get I
am norms and GM norms he's an I am now
and he'll try to get a GM norm next
month in our norm tournament okay G for
attacking the night when your night is
attacked you should move it away unless
your roofing Lee so you do what you want
looks like I'm high rate I do whatever I
want rook takes a six sacrificing his
night Grandmaster said thanks and then
the obvious move man it got really quiet
do you know at home what's that red g6
is that what he played Queen where Queen
f5 Wow am I know you mean you five hours
could
yeah yeah I don't know which one he did
should we vote which one's better
I like rook takes pawn so that must mean
in their movies right rook takes pawn
queen takes you're gonna play rook takes
at the best and maybe black hole plague
rip to b6 and you'll be confused okay f6
breaking what rule of mine never play of
six now Queen e5 okay now is this an
endgame where a middle game
nobody knows okay it's an endgame no no
she's right I told you I totally only
she's right so on an endgame in an
endgame you want a queen a pawn right
okay so f2 there you go what's that
Queen g3 that's check yeah yeah okay man
see there you go then he took the pawn
no you're right you're right okay and
then Queen e7 mm-hmm let's leave that
rook Queen f4
yum-yum-yum okay and computer says this
should be a draw and that's reasonable
because white was much worse the whole
game however just because it should be a
draw doesn't mean it will be a draw and
since black has a bishop and blacks
higher-rated and black was better the
whole game he went too far unlike me I
didn't go too far enough but he went too
far and f king g1 is an amazing move and
the reason it's amazing is my computer
says it's the best move and I was like
that's the best move Wow that's why
chess for the 21st century that's yeah I
remember more than one instance when a
commentator one time was me said the
computer move is this he's not playing
that and then that's the was played yeah
once it was an on that once who was
Carlson Carlson was me and Anand was
some European commentator like computer
says this is the right not never playing
that that's we played it so King g1
I don't think I would consider kingi one
but that's the right move now
there's some issue here this rook is on
these guys and this Queen is defending
these guys so taking that guy might be
risky
yeah rookie for rugby sevens probably
good for Wyatt
okay so h4 put it in H did white snatch
that pawn now there's his rooks hanging
okay so he moved his rook away and now
the computer said normal moves were
equal like Queen e5 so normal move and
instead black played for the wind which
is also playing for the laws this should
be a rook check and Bishop b5 I guess he
thought the rook would move and he would
play rook f1 then okay then maybe he'll
mate white and they'll be interesting
you know White's king is getting sort of
trapped okay and then white made the
move that he overlooked Queen behaved Oh
Queen B hey doesn't it seem like it
loses immediately but whites actually
winning immediately so I had a student a
long time ago I don't think he's alive
anymore and I assume so I've just taken
lessons anymore but one other excuse
could there possibly be and he I told
them if you never make a move where the
evaluation goes 1.5 different than the
current position for example it says
equal then it says you're not 1.6 that
would be a blunder I said if you never
do that you'll never lose and he said ok
we did it every game so anyway in this
game the computer said it was about
equal the clause and after this it said
whites up seven point four so that's
that's not a good move no no well one
thing I tell my students then they go
home and crying they don't understand it
now you can do that they say when you
make any chess move whatever you just
move is it where
that's true yeah so black just played
here remember when the bishop was on d7
and now it's not because it was their
last move so what did Y do to punish
that then I give them the answer they
don't know do you know at home you don't
know either
yeah even listening yeah rookie six and
that's tough the truth hurts
I think the bishop should be on d7 so
blight white doesn't do that yeah now
black has good defense of his king
except he doesn't yeah the bishop was
doing a good job defending everything on
the Kings side now you just lose the
bishops terrible on b5 and the rook
can't come back and help ever boo
trying too hard to win then you lose so
he moved his queen to the obvious square
we're giving away f6 that's not good it
was that Selena who said that I know I
know who said it
so what would a black actually do know
what's that yeah Queen da cause you keep
the pawn defended okay yum-yum-yum-yum
now White has many pawns and many
attacks King g7 always repeat good job
we thing good job
C good job then he's like all right I'll
win yeah and d6 threatening rookie 7 and
there's a lot of defenses to rookie 7
black found the best one resigned
otherwise Rickey sevens annoying real
I'm serious yeah
so this should be v was a good move yeah
so generally when young players like
roofing Lee but all young players like
you two are beating higher rated players
it's not because roofing Lee played 70
good moves in a row it's played 70
bedrooms it's because the game is up and
down or equal and then as the game gets
four five six hours long the older
player falls asleep and roofing Lee's
like dude up 13 like I get played ten
hours I don't care and then he
tactically takes all your pieces okay so
doesn't mean he played great he was
winning it means that he was alert at
the end of the game and his opponents
like a man rookie six and if he saw
rookie six he wouldn't have played
Bishop e5 but he was very concerned
about his own play he was like I'm gonna
play this should be five and then I'm
gonna play rook F 1 and I'm gonna play
Queen e5 and I'm the greatest now after
he was like oh wait a minute I can't
play this should be five no take-backs
in fact that's what my dad said to my
wife when I got married it's funny
because it's true that actually happened
okay okay so this is actually a complete
game but don't blink because it didn't
last very long and roofing leaves Wyatt
and his opponent decided castling is for
other people not for him and then he got
made it okay so what's happening with
them okay so it was very boring what
okay and then as I point out to my co
commentators many times it looks like
it's just alejandro now but when we look
at the games between good players when
it starts out like this and we fall
asleep then it gets really exciting when
they play exciting night or sand dragons
and they sacrifice all their pieces and
we're like oh boy then they have our
perpetual so usually when it starts out
really exciting it ends at a draw and
when it starts out like this then
everybody sacks everything later and
that's what happened so boring to start
but exciting later I actually had white
in this position I like white in this
position Queen c7 what what's that got
to do with castling takes e5 what's that
got to do with castling again like he
wanted to loose like I show you this
game if it's a drop not showing you this
game that's exactly what happened what
do you mean that makes perfect sense
okay so black is trying to do stuff
before he's developed his pieces and
castling doing stuff is never right he
shouldn't do nothing okay it's like what
Homer was a boxer don't do nothing okay
93
notice with the move c5 and e5 the white
squares aren't defended perfectly so
obviously why wants to play Knight b5
which would win so stakes Knight b5 as
suggested by me it's important that
black opens the center when his King is
there and White's castled it's important
if you want to see the game and then you
can see how white wins ok Queen defends
the bishop takes threatening rook e1
check and then I don't know black
resigns Knight takes d4 why castle why
castle you don't have to well you could
castle but probably he didn't like it I
don't blame him either defy is probably
good Knight takes bishop and take on c5
is probably good he thought Oh Castle
when he feels like it you know when he
felt like it the next game
there's always another game takes takes
tech c5 did he Castle now no now this
Bishop is good and now it's good or
nothing
yeah what's are you serious I just said
it how can that be a word so white wants
to open up files and diagonals and
everything for his rooks and bishops
because there's a black King there okay
and I was giving a lesson earlier I was
explaining to my student my opponent
didn't Castle I'm not gonna let him
Castle okay thanks and now the shocking
move takes you're barely shocked if
you've played the French defense or
against it you've seen this trick before
Queen takes Bishop Bishop b5 check also
there was a game good Tesco Fisher
Kotetsu that could be right from the
Olympiad where he hung his Queen on d3
year d4 d5 I move like 11 ya know as
opponent yeah okay so black didn't hang
his Queen and white played track and the
black castle anybody who's watching here
knows that's a one o'clock class move
they would they would Castle for sure
there's that doesn't stop them that's
that's got enough to do with their play
that's legally illegal don't care about
that
okay so Bishop e6 obviously right okay
now when you're playing somebody who I
lecture on for this class that means
they're very young based on what year it
is 21st century that means you don't
want this position you want boring
blocked up fall asleep equal endgame you
don't want your king is in the center
they have two bishops time to sacrifice
crazy tactics you don't want that okay
so he picked the wrong guy to play this
way against to leave his King in the Sun
as a whole game that was last week's
lecture well that's okay rookie five
he's talking a castle or as you would
say you could but you don't want her all
right now
white wanted to play Bishop b5 and Queen
a4 and those were all the worst moves
ever now they're not the worst ones
enter anymore now they're good because
we keep it kicking the Queen out yay
Bishop c5 and now he Castle well 1
o'clock class it's funny if you
cancelled and then your opponent said
that's illegal no it's actually better
to say it's illegal I'm explaining why
no because then due to the touchmove
role black will play King d7 the bet the
best defense
okay so 97 forking everything and white
resigned because his pieces are forked
is that right Selena
that's curved stop teasing your sister
alright somebody suggested Bishop b5
that's legal what's that
rookies thing there's a pawn on f7 you
missed it right there Ricky six
that's what Ken Westwood do now black
has two legal moves F takes E and
Queenie seven now super Grand Master
would resign but this ain't no super
Grandmaster so Fe Queen h5 check now
this is very porous Ford spin ship on
black star black resigned that's that's
the worst in this position we'll never
know although I'll ask him next month
we'll never know if you if you've done
this or this well we don't know what he
would have done like you're you're not
playing the game okay I know what you
would do yeah you wouldn't see this no
because I just told you you would take
with a bishop that I tie there yeah
that's right okay that loses because you
take it and then you block yeah so
actually even though this is cooler when
I'm playing in a tournament I do that
just in case I'm wrong even I can't be
wrong I still do it because it could be
wrong on it all right so it's live g6
and getting made it only way you at home
were terrible I forgot okay dear here
mate damn and for those we were really
terrible we'll do it this way and then
you take the rook no I'm just kidding
okay so yeah that was that was good now
black had the advantage of being set up
for the next game very advantageous look
at Wyatt well no wait try to move that
so that's not bad okay last but least
okay now in this game unlike the
previous games of the previous games
also roofing was black should we flip
the board what if my comer comes in
there we go okay so when I'm
look at this game the previous part of
the game you don't want to see I I
didn't realize black is a pawn up so
black should have good technique okay
when you have opposite side mating
attacks it would be better if your
opponent was like needle Schechter that
would be reasonable right okay not
somebody born in the 21st century okay
if your opponent is 13 14 15 years old
and it's an opposite side mating attack
you'll probably be the one getting mated
so that's like what they're good at
now it's funny about this this was
played this year and every time I look
at a roofing league game his ratings 100
points higher
so his ratings even higher than this now
so I make sure I keep don't play them
next year see that was the mistake I
made
I played Sam 7 three years ago and then
I played him two years ago that was the
mistake I should have played him three
years ago and not played him two years
ago that was a blunder on my part so
I'll play roofing Lee this year then
I'll never play him again although he's
already 15 so I think I'm already in
trouble ok so a lot of people would win
simply because blacks upon up black has
a beautiful night black has an attack
and white doesn't but roofing Lee was
was born in this century so oh he's
gonna pound his opponent so after rook
c1 defending the c2 upon yeah b3
okay so white ignored it and said y'all
defend my rook on c1 and now I'm
threatening this C is he also tiny by
the bishop
so it's this rook I'm so confused yeah I
can't say they move backwards I flip the
board give me a break yeah okay so a
Queenie one and they agreed to a draw
cuz white solid right Selena
but in Simon's like they agreed to a
draw the class must be over yeah yeah
okay now if you're born in the 21st
century and you play b3 what's your next
move
see you were born in 21st century so you
answered right a3 yeah and the truth
hurts what I like is this rook over here
which looks defensive it's gonna look
not defensive sewn yeah okay so Wow
super grandma Esther's were playing
white would resign because this is gonna
get bad in a second this is gonna be bad
okay but he tried to defend rook digs b3
and he doubled the rooks most people
just take out beats who check but the
threat stronger than the execution that
nonsense you've always heard yeah yeah
so how do we defend here hmm know what
b1x clam okay and obviously he took and
now we're gonna vote you can vote for
the green move the red move or the other
move I can make it yellow I don't know
how let me hold on let me hold on let me
hold on let me text Coldplay to see how
it's yellow
oh wait Chris Martin's daughter's
birthday is today never mind and what's
his daughter's name we're close
what's that Apple yeah yeah she's 12
she's 12 today okay so obviously King
takes is not good because Rick takes a -
okay and this fruitcakes isn't good for
similar reasons Rick takes a toon queen
a tree we have to have screw family we
do okay so this truck took obviously all
right Knight c3
oh no he hung his Knight oh what a pond
sir so what happens if we take it the
class doesn't know they're like hung is
night
what's that yeah there you go and the
truth hurts
and then after here yeah I don't have
don't get attacked by 13 14 15 do that
because they see tactics don't play we
faintly write that down that's not gonna
be good for your score okay now I
understand we can't take as a queen f1
but this is me so we should do something
about that you always want to resign
everything what kind of different oh
come on how about this rook takes that
looks good for black so this is no good
this is no good I know what we'll do
we'll trade everything that should be
equal there we go yeah trade all the
rugs draw tanks and draw greed I mean
that's a lot of attackers on e2 isn't it
that's a lot well I would have resigned
a while ago but I guess if I was playing
a one-minute game what would you playing
a one-minute game then game on e6
reasonable reasonable I think King b2
I'm expecting Queen takes c6 online King
B to run away well safe
No okay so he finally resigned like King
Beach is the only reasonable move and
then I mean everything wins and I'm
probably missing meeting one but I know
this one's so I know this is good
without Queenie - I wouldn't yeah
so in most of the games whether he was
better or worse or both he got a big
attack whether he should ever not and
then he pulverized his opponents even in
the endgame
there are two end games where he made it
his opponents man chess is tough so
roofing Lee will be here next month for
them - it'll be next month for them
right yeah and he's playing in the norm
tournament he's actually probably the
highest rated I am in the US by quite a
bit and he's trying to get GM norms
because then you become a GM hooray and
as a special bonus he's also gonna play
in the US Junior Championship and I've
been informed so well Jeffrey's young so
that's gonna be a strong jr. cuz
probably other people I don't know that
are playing like I shot chandra oxide
chandra is also playing in the norm
tournament so for some reason even
though i'm a GM they get to beat me and
become a GM that's not fair why can't I
beat them and stop them from becoming a
GM it doesn't work like that